die wenigsten von euch werden sich noch
daran erinnern können oder haben
überhaupt jemals davon gehört aber vor
gut 50 jahren sollte science fiction
realität werden die größte und
komfortabelste raumstation der welt
ausgestattet mit einem state of the art
weltraumlabor skylab division der nasa
leben im all die mondlandung lag erst
wenige jahre zurück und alles schien
möglich aber erst arbeitet die zeit
gegen sie dann häuften sich
unvorhergesehene probleme und am ende
stand die nasa kurz vor einer weltweiten
katastrophe das hier ist die
unglaubliche geschichte von skylab
[Musik]
liga
1969 betrat neil armstrong als erster
mensch den mond und beendete damit
vorerst das space race zwischen den usa
und der sowjetunion
doch schon vor ihrem erfolg wuchsen die
ambitionen der usa man wollte eine
raumstation bauen die idee von skylab
war geboren über 2,2 milliarden dollar
flossen damals in das projekt um die
erste raumstation des planeten erde
wirklichkeit werden zu lassen heute
wären das ungefähr zehn milliarden
dollar aber tatsächlich ein ziemliches
schnäppchen denn zum vergleich das
apollo-programm kostete umgerechnet
circa 150 milliarden dollar so einfach
das fünfzehnfache und auch die
internationale raumstation hat es ganz
grob 150 milliarden dollar gekostet wie
baut man also mit vergleichsweise so
wenig geld eine ganze raumstation um das
zu beantworten müssen wir noch mal ein
paar jahre zurück springen während die
ganze welt zum mond schaute arbeitete
ein kleiner teil der nasa schon am
nächsten großen meilensteine und 1965
legte eine kleine abteilung der nasa dem
us-kongress pläne für eine raumstation
vor die abteilung hieß apollo
applications office und ihre idee war
ist das aufgebaute momentum nach der
hoffentlich erfolgreichen mondlandung
nicht abklingen zu lassen stattdessen
wollte man mit einer neuen vision den
hyde weiter befeuern dem leben im all
aber das war selbst für die nasa damals
noch science-fiction ein mensch auf dem
mond okay das könnte mit viel geld viel
glück und ziemlich viel größenwahn
klappen aber ein mensch in einer station
für mehrere wochen in der
schwerelosigkeit
das war das problem man wollte ein
großes neues projekt im all finanzieren
bevor überhaupt die ein mensch den mond
betreten hatte und davon war der
damalige leiter der nasa james webb
nicht wirklich überzeugt und ja das ist
der james webb des neuen
weltraumteleskops alle infos dazu habe
ich übrigens hier in einem video kompakt
zusammengefasst man fand damals also
einen kompromiss das team sollte alte
teile der apollo-missionen
wiederverwerten ohne zu wissen ob die
mondlandung überhaupt erfolgreich wird
wie wir heute alle wissen hat es
geklappt oder doch nicht ob es die
mondlandung wirklich gegeben hat das
wissen wahrscheinlich nur die echsen
menschen aber was wir auf jeden fall
sicher wissen ist dass nord die pn der
sponsor unseres heutigen videos ist und
zehn jahre alt wird aber anstatt dass
wir nord wp etwas schenken wie sich
gehören würde schenk nord vpn uns etwas
wenn ihr mit dem kot doktor watson ein
zwei jahres abo abschließt dann bekommt
ihr nämlich nicht nur einen gratismonat
geschenkt sondern erhalte zum jubiläum
zusätzlich entweder ein ein monats ein
ein jahres oder sogar ein zwei jahres
paket gratis obendrauf ihr bekommt also
auf jeden fall zwei monate gratis und
mit etwas glück sogar noch viel mehr
knoten ist kinderleicht auf dem
smartphone tablet oder pc eingerichtet
und ermöglicht es euch das internet so
anzusteuern als wärt ihr in 60 ländern
überall auf der welt gleichzeitig das
bedeutet ihr könnt euch zum beispiel
weiterhin filme wie joker auf netflix
ansehen der seit mitte februar nicht
mehr in deutschland verfügbar ist und
wenn ihr den noch nicht gesehen habt
tanz heute wäre es auf jeden fall
nachholen auch bei der streaming
qualität müsst ihr keine abstriche
machen nur vpn wird eure
internetgeschwindigkeit nicht verringern
und kann im gegenteil sogar helfen sich
schneller zu machen wie immer gilt ihr
braucht keine armut nord pvn speichert
nicht auf welche webseite unterwegs seid
und wenn ihr nicht zufrieden seid habt
ihr 30 tage zeit muss euch anders zu
überlegen und euer geld zurückzubekommen
nur pr.com / doktor watson und beim
checkout den code doktor watson benutzen
um mindestens zwei monate nur gbm gratis
zu bekommen und damit zurück zum video
nach der erfolgreichen mondlandungen die
definitiv stattgefunden hat sank das
öffentliche interesse an der nasa leider
rapide das space race gegen die
sowjetunion war gewonnen und der
us-kongress kurze das budget der nasa
laut eigenen aussagen war das
apollo-programm ein opfer des eigenen
erfolges nach den budgetkürzungen und
dem schwindenden interesse an der
bemannten raumfahrt sollte skylab das
apollo team zusammenhalten und dem
raumfahrtprogramm eine mögliche zukunft
bieten doch dann begannen die probleme
1971 zwei jahre nach der ersten
mondlandung war es nicht die nasa
sondern roskosmos die die erste
raumstation der menschheit ins all
brachten jedoch zu einem hohen preis in
der russischen raumstation saljut 1
lebten insgesamt drei kosmonauten von
denen bedauerlicherweise keiner leben
zur erde zurückkehren sollte durch ein
leck in der luke des raumschiffes konnte
unbemerkt luft entweichen und das
kostete die gesamte besatzung das leben
so eine tragödie wollte die nasa mit
skylab um jeden preis vermeiden deswegen
sollte alles bis ins kleinste detail
geprobt werden um die crew auf das leben
im all vorzubereiten ist skylab sogar
wortwörtlich auf tauchstation gegangen
so konnte man außeneinsätze wie zum
beispiel reparaturen unter wasser üben
die nasa hatte sogar innerhalb des
unterwasser sky labs den
sauerstoffgehalt so angepasst dass er
dem im weltall entspricht also dem
sauerstoffgehalt in der station
natürlich über 56 tage verbrachten
astronauten im unterwasser skylab und
simulierten ihre mission im all
das hier war das herzstück von skylab
der orbit workshop in dem sollten die
astronauten arbeiten und auch leben
können mit einem durchmesser von 6,7 und
einer länge von 14,6 metern war der
workshop der größte teil der station
von hier aus sollte die sonne genauer
erforscht der effekt der
schwerelosigkeit auf den menschen
untersucht und unzählige weitere
versuche durchgeführt werden genauso wie
man das unter wasser geprobt hatte
gebaut wurde der workshop aus der
dritten stufe einer sohn 5 rakete das
ziel von sky war aber vor allem anderen
das überleben der crew denn ob und wie
menschen für wochen im all überhaupt
überleben könnten das wusste damals noch
niemand
am 14 mai
1973 war es dann soweit die station
sollte von einer saturn 5 rakete ins all
geschickt werden die vorbereitungen im
kennedy space center waren abgeschlossen
und die nasa war sich sicher sie wäre
auf alles vorbereitet auf der startrampe
daneben stand sogar schon die nächste
rakete bereit mit der sollten die ersten
drei astronauten konrektorin und white
zur station fliegen sobald skylab im
orbit der erde platziert war die nasa
startet den countdown dieser 55 mitsamt
skylab bahnte sich ihren weg ins all und
die katastrophe nahm ihren lauf
um die astronauten vor hitzestrahlung
und meteoriten zu schützen entwarf man
eine besondere schutzschicht für die
station sie trug den namen micromeet
erzielt und sollte nicht nur schutz
gegen kleinere objekte im all bieten
sondern auch mit einer speziell für den
einsatz design und wärme beschichtung
aus aluminium und gold für die richtige
temperatur in der station sorgen aber
genau diese schutzhülle löste sich nur
63 sekunden nach dem start von der
station auf einen schlag war klar skylab
würde quasi unbewohnbar sein doch damit
nicht genug es löste sich auch noch
eines der solarmodule dass die station
mit strom versorgen sollte und
beschädigte dabei ein zweites ohne
schutzhülle und nur mit zwei der vier
solarmodule schafft es die station zwar
noch in den vorhergesehenen erd orbit
aber innen waren es jetzt bis zu 65 grad
celsius
darüber hinaus brach dann auch immer
wieder die stromversorgung zusammen aus
dem labor im all wurde schnell eine
sauna im all ohne strom die drei
astronauten dürfen natürlich nicht
starten und der traum war geplatzt
zumindest fürs erste während alles
drunter und drüber ging musste die nasa
vor allem eins handeln dieses
unglaublich teure projekt konnte man
nicht einfach so aufgeben und deswegen
machten die ingenieure der nasa genau
das was sie nun mal am besten können
innerhalb von nur zehn tagen arbeitete
man tag und nacht an einer lösung und
baute schlussendlich eine provisorische
zwölf meter lange und vier meter breite
schutzhülle diese musste aber natürlich
erst mal ins all gelangen am 25 mai 1973
gerade mal elf tage nach dem ersten
start doktor conrad josef karl rinn und
paul weitz am skylab an sie befestigten
die neue schutzhülle mehr ein großes
sonnensegel über der außenhülle der
station so sank die temperatur innerhalb
des weltraumlabors um die nötige
stromversorgung wiederherzustellen
berichtete man die stationen neu aus so
dass die verbleibenden solarpanels mehr
strom produzierten und dann konnten die
astronauten tatsächlich ihre 28 tägige
mission beginnen
die crew begann es sich langsam auf der
station gemütlich zu machen und schon
bald konnte es mit den ersten
experimenten losgehen das größte und
längste experiment waren übrigens die
astronauten selber mit 28 tagen im all
stellten die drei astronauten den rekord
für die damals längste zeit im all auf
und dabei sollte es nicht bleiben später
kamen weitere crews und die dritte und
letzte die skylab besuchte blieb sogar
noch deutlich länger 84 tage im weltall
darüber hinaus wollte man auch generelle
fragen der schwerelosigkeit klären zum
beispiel wie würde eine spinne ihr netz
im all leben klar wer auch sofort meine
erste idee gewesen wer will nicht auf
einer super engen raumstation mit
spinnen zusammenleben super idee aber
abgesehen von spinnen experimenten stand
auch noch eine genauere untersuchung der
sonne auf dem plan skylab lieferte die
bis dato genauesten bilder und
untersuchungen von sonneneruptionen
skylab hat also trotz einer riesigen
katastrophe beim start bahnbrechende
experimente möglich gemacht und
obendrein auch noch neue rekorde im
weltall aufgestellt also alles in allem
doch noch ein erfolg naja nicht ganz
denn skylab war nach einem jahr in
betrieb schon so abgenutzt dass die nasa
erst einmal keine weiteren missionen
planen wollte man hatte vor die station
per space shuttle in einen anderen ort
zu schieben um sie zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt wieder in betrieb zu nehmen
doch soweit sollte es nicht kommen
während zum start noch alle augen der
welt auf skylab gerichtet waren
interessierte sich ein jahr später kein
mensch mehr für die fortschrittliche
raumstation erst 1979 wurde skylab
wieder zum gesprächsthema als sich die
nächste katastrophe anbahnt die station
drohte abzustürzen vier jahre früher als
die nasa geplant hatte skylab war nun
auf kollisionskurs mit der erde
die nachricht verbreitete sich wie ein
lauffeuer und die menschen baten den
damaligen us-präsidenten jimmy carter
sogar die station abzuschießen fun fact
in den usa wurden damals über
versicherungen verkauft für den fall
dass man von der station getroffen wurde
es war allerdings eher so ein
marketing-gag sogar in deutschland
machte sich angst breit da sich niemand
sicher war wo die 80 tonnen schwere
station abstürzen würde in der hamburger
morgenpost schrieb man damals gefahr für
deutschland doch soweit kam es nicht die
nasa brachte skylab per fernsteuerung so
gut es ging in position um größere
schäden auf der erde zu vermeiden
trotzdem war bis zur letzten sekunde
nicht klar wo die station genau
abstürzen würde letztendlich war es
weder in deutschland noch in den usa
sondern in australien und über dem
indischen ozean
verletzte gab es damals gott sei dank
keine und so war der traum von skylab
endgültig ausgeträumt aber die nase
hielt an der idee fest skylab legte den
grundstein für leben im all und zeigte
dass es grundsätzlich möglich ist wäre
die stationen nach ihrem missglückten
start nicht gerettet worden hätte uns
das wahrscheinlich einige jahre wenn ich
sogar vielleicht jahrzehnte in der
erforschung des alls zurückgeworfen die
nasa hat mit ihrem langzeit experiment
im all pionierarbeit geleistet
das heißt ohne skylab hätte es
wahrscheinlich viel viel länger
gebraucht und eine basis auf dem mond
hätte heute auch noch niemand für
möglich gehalten
jetzt sind wir nicht mehr weit davon
entfernt die artemis missionen sollen
nun nach über 50 jahren menschen wieder
zurück auf den mond bringen und dort
dann eine basis errichten leben im all
und da ist noch nicht schluss mit den
gesammelten erkenntnissen in den 2030er
jahren soll es dann endlich zum mars
gehen falls euch interessiert wie die
nasa diese riesigen projekte jetzt
gerade vorbereitet und was da alles
geplant ist dann schaut euch doch unsere
video reihe zu den artemis mission an wo
wir genau darüber berichten und euch
erzählen was da alles gerade abgeht und
was alles geplant ist und vergesst
natürlich nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
um die erste maß landung nicht zu
verpassen wie immer viereck fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig patrick